i am concerned but i'll do
whatever i have to do to survive
december is the first month where i'm
i'm
i've got that kind of nasty feeling
inside there's a lot of fear
and a lot of insecurity out there these
are residents of mount airy
a historic neighborhood in northwest
philadelphia that's home to 30 000
people of all walks of life
the community's economic and racial
diversity offer a glimpse into what
americans across the country
are going through nine months into the
coronavirus pandemic
residents here have lost their jobs
dozens of businesses have scaled back
ours or
employees and the city like many others
recently put in place new restrictions
my covert anxiety level actually is it's
pretty high
and i mean i'm very hopeful we're going
to have a vaccine
but i'm very concerned about you know
long-term economic impacts
i traveled to this tight-knit community
to speak to residents who are struggling
with different hardships brought on by
the same virus
to understand how they're navigating a
new financial reality as they're forced
to cope with the uncertainty that lies
ahead
you know time is
chris marcel is a jazz musician in a
good month he'd typically earn three or
four thousand dollars playing in
restaurants and bars and teaching piano
lessons on the side
but this year his income along with the
entire live music industry has been
crushed by the pandemic
all my money's gone i'm good until the
end of the month at this point and just
floating by and then what i don't know
that's that's the uh
that's the challenge i guess that's the
unknown factor
you didn't have a traditional job in the
sense that you couldn't get laid off
or paid severance and that's that's
something that's been a
big problem because you know booking
myself
we all look months in advance normally
right now i'm looking at
june and july where am i working i need
my job security now so i'm comfortable
with
bills and stuff then now what how's your
gig booking going
um it's not with the way restrictions
are coming and going
i'm finding out two days beforehand oh
by the way you're not working thursday
like many pennsylvanians chris collected
an additional 600
a week in unemployment benefits through
the federal pandemic unemployment
assistance program
but those checks stopped in july even
though he believes he's eligible for
additional aid
he's had trouble filing claims online
the pennsylvania department of labor
said that it can't comment on
individual cases but that it notifies
people when the status of their claims
change and when payments are stopped or
held for various reasons
now that his savings have dwindled chris
is worried he won't have enough to pay
the mortgage for the new house he bought
at the beginning of the year
just looking at the bank account and
realizing all right when i pay
a b and c i got x left over that's gotta
that's gotta be it there's no known
income for right now and
what few things i do have in the works
before the end of the month
i can't guarantee they're going to
happen chris stopped paying liability
insurance earlier this year
and he says he uses small hacks to save
money like
getting groceries from a local
non-profit that distributes produce
he hopes to receive more stimulus money
and that a vaccine can help the
restaurant and entertainment industries
make a comeback
yet his anxiety continues to grow
can you see the light at the end of the
tunnel i want to
i do want to because that's who i am as
a person but it's it's that that
i feel like it's getting farther away
[Music]
chris gets his inexpensive produce from
jessica rights
she and her husband nick freeman are
catering professionals who
like many americans chose to pivot after
being laid off from their full-time jobs
what began as a mission to help their
neighbors get produce at the beginning
of the pandemic
has turned into a full-blown non-profit
known as mount airy groceries
which delivers low cost and in most
cases free boxes of food to people all
over the city with the help of other
organizations
tell me about the need what types of
people are you serving there's a wide
range of people that we serve there are
people that are
newly food insecure because of kovid
there are people that are at home
who are afraid to go the grocery store
because they're chronically ill
i will say that probably the largest
population of people that we serve
however
are mothers at home with school aged
children they say their goal is to
continue growing and serving their
community
but they like many of their neighbors
are feeling the stress of not having
stable jobs
i heard coronavirus one day and then
like
less than two weeks later i was out of a
job and i think that was the case for
millions of people in this country
nick received some unemployment benefits
early in the pandemic and has since
taken a part-time job
but nine months in with foster kids at
home and bills that are piling up they
say they might have to make
cuts like selling a car and a cabin they
bought earlier in the year
everything now we are very very
carefully going through what's necessary
or not jessica and nick are now trying
to find a way to structure salaries into
their non-profit
without a paycheck jessica says she'll
have to take a job elsewhere
something she no longer wants to do
especially now that she's seen the food
insecurity in her community
where are your covet anxiety levels i
think people can take a little bit of
anxiety you have that flight or fight
response
long term sustained
worry and stress at some point
there's like a there's a breaking point
and unfortunately i think for many of us
we're right about there i didn't expect
this to happen everything is pretty shut
down i worry about my neighbors i'm
worried about my friends
dana profit has been helping jessica and
nick with their mount airy grocery's
website
a copywriter who was laid off from her
job of 10 years in august
she's been taking on side projects to
enhance her portfolio
but applying for jobs at age 49 is
something she never
imagined she'd have to do what is it
like to job search
after being at a company for so long
it's
difficult it i had to relearn a lot of
things
every rejection or none response that i
receive
is depressing i get i get blue is it
hard to not take it personally i always
take it personally you do
how can you not want me i'm fabulous
dana started taking online classes in
graphic design so she can
ultimately become a one-stop shop for
small businesses looking to start a
website
so far she's relied on severance and
unemployment benefits to get by
but if she doesn't get additional
stimulus money from washington
she's worried about covering big
expenses like health insurance
especially in the middle of a pandemic
rent worries her too
though she says she's not getting
evicted because her sister is her
landlord
you're in a position like many americans
where you are lucky to have a family
yes but you don't you've said you don't
want to lean on them too much
no why i don't want to drain their
finances to help me
so i rather for us just to
hold each other up rather than me
climbing on their shoulders
to survive there's people to help me
but i'm going to try to save pull myself
up first
but how long it will take mount airy's
residents and americans across the
country
to pull themselves up is still unknown
despite a vaccine rollout across the u.s
and additional stimulus from washington
these neighbors
say they want to be optimistic but the
uncertainty that lies ahead
is weighing on them looking into 2021
are you
concerned at all about your ability to
pay your bills and meet your obligations
if i have to work for jobs i've done it
before i'll do it again
but just anything i have to do to
keep the heat on the lights on and a
roof over my head
and food on the table i will i'll find a
job and do it